hey gang it's your old pal uncle hank
real quick before we get the show
started just want to give you a couple
reminders
number one atlantic city new jersey june
18th 8 30 show
sold the [ __ ] out so we added a 10 30
show
if you want to come see us in atlantic
city grab some tickets for the 10 30
show
also chicago illinois june 24th both
shows
sold the [ __ ] out again so guess what
we're adding a third show
june 22nd that tuesday at seven o'clock
get some tickets for that come and see
us and lastly
if you live in indiana indianapolis come
on out and see us june 23rd
at helium comedy club it's gonna be a
great time now let's get the show
started
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley it tastes homemade
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
r.u garbage oh yeah a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
found their growth to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash yeah i'm your host dave foley
coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antoni's basement she
continues
to be a thorn in our side yeah mother's
day i'm having a nice brunch with my
family i get a call from a buddy of mine
who i used to wait tables with who now
works at a fridays
today's over there demanding turnout
that she gets a free
lunch on mother's day she don't even
have kids i'm aware of that
teddy she's trying to [ __ ] milk him
for a free mother's day she said that's
always been the case what she's
referring to
is veterans day okay veterans get a free
meal
so there'll be some stolen valor coming
up
for a plate of a sampler my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me
i can't give him too much [ __ ] he's my
boss this guy saved my life in vietnam
all right
he is the andy dufresne of argue garbage
i'll be in san juan taneo once once it's
all crashes
kid puts out a cold beer too i'll tell
you that i'll give it up for my partner
my pal
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
what's up happy to be here uh as always
thanks for tuning in
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and patreon.com you can sign up
get bonus episodes
of ayg episodes of hard feelings and we
do a live stream every month
with our top tier guest it's a good
[ __ ] time but how are the numbers
the numbers are true
they're cooking also we're going to be
posting footage from the live shows that
we're doing on the patreon so another
reason to sign up
get that content baby fantastic and a
lot of that goes to our producer
extraordinaire he's a magic man
very funny stand-up comedian from
chicago illinois he's here on the
[ __ ] new york scene
we were out saturday [ __ ] cruising
around hitting some spots
smoking some cigs it was a good time
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what up boys hey
t-bone
dudes breakthrough kippy brushes teeth
in the shower
changes tune yesterday fresh bagel
untoasted
nice new york style nice stung he hated
hated it oh
get daddy three out of ten i felt like
it was late for work [ __ ]
sucks ass [ __ ] happy i'm not trusting
anybody with that haircut go ride your
rebel scooter back to wherever
yeah my conservative scooter
gang that can either be here nor there
uh we could not be more excited to have
our incredibly incredibly special
hot one back with us today if you
haven't seen her episode you got to go
back and check it out most of you have
cause most of your [ __ ] comment about
it still to this day all the time
we love her she is coast to coast
trash she's all over the place the queen
of trash
you do move around very very well you're
here you're there you're posting this
you're posting that we could not be more
excited to have her here with this
she's going to be answering your
questions give it up for the one the
only and she brought [ __ ] slurpees i
mean come on what are we doing here
kim cogdon everybody hey hey what's up
everybody
thank you buddy beautiful you're welcome
yeah i mean nothing like showing up 30
minutes late with slurps
that's the trashiest way i could show up
you're in on your own
you're on your own time kind of girl
though right you know to be honest i'm
usually very on time with things when it
comes to spots and stuff like that when
i'm hosting i've noticed you're all
you're always right on time you're
probably yeah i like to be on remember
when the time i
ran the light though no oh okay i ran
the light with you and you were not
happy once
no that don't put that on me i'm
probably the real agent i don't even
remember
everybody thinks he's a big lovable hey
i run a tight ship i don't know what to
tell you
i'm not like bozo mcgee over here show
up when you want
yeah i'm pretty good at being on time i
hate being late but i think the
i'm just getting used to i'm driving in
the city for the first time which is
crazy
it's a nightmare because when i said
that i meant it you you're you're that
you're
you grew up in florida you were working
out of la during the pandemic you're
there
you're you're you're in la you're here
you know what i mean you're zipping
around you're flying around
where are you getting where'd you get a
car in new york um
uh one of my friends let me borrow his
car while he was gone for the week that
is some weed culture [ __ ] right there
[Laughter]
is it a van yeah and it's um it's a
subaru it's like a 2004 subaru
wow that fits the bill barely turns no
i'd be surprised it barely turns i'm
shocked that i'm not dead
wait what does that mean i'll barely
turn like it does you have to be
speeding in order for the steering wheel
to work
that sounds weird i thought you meant
turns like the engine i was like damn
she knows that term that's real trashy
can't get the engine to turn something
wrong with the catalytic i don't know
um yeah you're all over the place yeah
it's been i mean i took uh advantage of
the pandemic and
you know had my fifty dollar flights my
trash
i know she'll be like oh she's like in a
cave like all right glenn and [ __ ] all
right
i'm like yeah in a cave with a
pre-rolled in her mouth everyone's at
home getting sick with their parents
like idiots i'm gonna go do it in the
[ __ ]
colorado river well you have one of my
favorite moments from
any are you garbage is when your mom
made a cameo
your mom thought she was on star search
and it was [ __ ] fantastic
she was like oh hey like she came in and
stole the [ __ ] show
because we did it on zoom the first one
yeah and she came into your bedroom and
was like who's on tv
which one's simon it actually became a
problem with her
and working at home and she loves
attention too much she's also like
she gives off a little bit of stifler's
mom's vibes yeah a little [ __ ] mom
vibes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like i get
it you want to be [ __ ]
up who doesn't
i have to write this off later so
yeah um it was one of my favorite things
she put her feet
in my twitch stream really i had to
kick her off she just waited she's doing
i forgot
for free for free shout out to mrs c
over there doing it right she knows what
the boys like huh
feet first these days i was sick i like
had made a funny comment i was like oh
they're asking for your feet ha ha
and then i kept streaming and then i see
like a foot behind me
in my ear and i was like start going
i forgot that you did twitch too which i
don't [ __ ] get but it's so funny that
you do
i don't get it either it all fit it just
all fits with you you're playing video
games on there yeah
and people watch you play video games
they pay to watch me play
and what video games are you playing i
play fortnite i play
call of duty i play a little bit of
rocket league
i was trying to get into 2k recently i'm
gonna get into some fifa
so you guys check me out on twitch.tv
if you have amazon prime you subscribe
for free there you go
you're making decent cash on there i
make pretty decent cash i make like
rent payments
he's trying to figure out how to work an
xbox it's just fully playing minesweeper
for four hours
i'll play snake for 20 minutes that's it
it starts hurting my eyes
fantastic well thank you for sitting in
with us thank you for coming in of
course uh as you folks out there know
that when you sign up uh
to the patreon you get your question
asked on the air and that's what we're
gonna do nice little family yep
we're gonna bounce some things off the
questions have been unbelievable i saw
one on twitter today that was
is it garbage um if you're named after
your parent but not the middle name
yeah it's pretty true oh it's so good
but not the middle like you have to have
both
yeah to be like a junior or a third or a
fourth
it has to be like jonathan like if your
mom's his name was kim elizabeth
cogden and your name kim sarah cogden oh
what is your full name by the way
kimberly allison congdon
nice very white yeah nice and is that
your mom's last name too was your mom
last name cognitive no my mom's a
benitez
you know we don't have the same lessons
are you kidding why are you going to say
i was going to say your mom's a [ __ ]
but
i have to take the shot i'm sorry when i
was younger like my i was like i can't
wait to have my own family so we could
have one name on the mailbox
yeah i don't think that's gonna happen
i love you kim but i mean
it might be that allison might be
pushing you you guys want a taquito
jesus you can't i'd love them but i
can't they'll tell me if it was just you
and me yeah i'd eat the whole thing why
can't you guy i got these guys watching
me like oh yeah i mean we're just
getting he's watching you yeah we're
trying to
yeah i mean why why are they are you
banned from taquitos what do you do
i'm all blocked up my arteries are all
jacked up i shouldn't have brought you
the slurpee
i know of course not push it over he's
gonna be drinking mine in a second
you're like a new prison guard you don't
know you don't know what i can't
have hey this new babysitter is [ __ ]
awesome
why do you shove the slurpee in his ass
that's foley that's what he does
he's hiding it it hits them quicker i
like to boof it
what are they these are monterey cheese
and chicken taquitos
and i used to have this i remember your
breakfast chocolate chips and um
yeah her slur her breakfast would be
taquitos ruffles chips and a slurpee why
don't we talk every day before high
school
high school every day i haven't had a
taquito in a long time
six weeks
i [ __ ] love these things dude i have
this specific flavor yeah what am i
gonna i've had them all
six weeks i served them at my wedding
it's like it came out of a five-star
restaurant yeah they're top shelf so
[ __ ] good
the monterey jack chicken taquito stands
on its own
okay there's a trick though they don't
hold on they don't need it but if they
had like a sauce that came with them
good night they used to have the ranch
packets by the hot dogs i can't do the
packets it's got to be a dunk it's got
to be a dip
do you ever catch it well you could
steal the little donkey ranches i used
to do that too i used to just steal them
you know the package of blue cheese and
rain i mean you can't steal
feel like that's what they're there for
you know you can buy those kim
no i'm just about 25 on a ramp you steal
two you'll steal little things like that
i i'll admit i stopped stealing exactly
like a year ago
i was like you know feds were swarming
me
only because i feel like i reached my um
felony amount
on target and walmart and you're
stealing from the players
what do you mean who are you winona
yeah i ryder i have a thing about
stealing like from big stores like
walmart it makes me feel better
dude so many people have that it's so
crazy it makes me feel like i'm doing
something right
i like supporting small businesses
that's why i don't know i buy from small
businesses and i steal from big ones
i'm a ghetto robin hood like an avenger
saving the planet one blouse at a time
yeah i was like i can't get arrested
stealing [ __ ]
hershey's bar at this point that's my
biggest
can you imagine if someone puts out a
picture on twitter they're sending it
right to you guys that's what i always
say
if we're gonna be the first we're gonna
be we're gonna be tagged in your mud
i always said that even when i was a kid
i didn't want to be the fat kid getting
caught with a [ __ ] laffy taffy
right that really worked out for you
for a living legally though
legally we have to do this to keep the
patreon what was your biggest heist
i mean they're never big talk to me to
steal like clothes
hold on if you stop that means that you
got there was a moment when you got a
little scared
i've never gotten caught i've never
gotten close to caught but i know that
it's a game of numbers and i've gotten
away with it since i was that's what
yeah so i'm like i'm 30 and i can afford
the [ __ ] detergent
yeah i'll buy it but you're still in
detergent well that's what i stole last
time
can i tell you why can i tell you it's
unbelievable
i was in a hurry i was gonna go buy
detergent this is the last time i stole
from walmart walmart if you're hearing
this
[ __ ] you um i don't think the walton's
tune into are you
um i literally and when i steal i do
this to the camera so they know that no
you're [ __ ] up what are you the
[ __ ] riddler
i love it next time
four goons pick you up out front would
you get boss
so the last time i stole the turget was
detergent and that's because i
accidentally grabbed softener i went
through the self checkout
realized it was detergent i pressed the
call for help button i waited about 15
minutes and i said you know what i'm
gonna go get my own detergent and just
leave
you don't have to did you keep the
softener no i left it i paid for the
softener and then took the detergent
which is more expensive that's not too
bad but it's like
what do you now you're going to have to
pay for the time i waited 15 minutes
i mean at least thrown off my whole day
off this weight so that costs at least
seven dollars
joints aren't going to roll themselves
i got taquitos
yeah of course i got to go play video
games hold on i do see what you're
saying a little bit with that
i also see i also respect the fact that
you're being honest about it because let
me tell you something
there's a lot of people out there a lot
of people's moms and grandmoms and aunts
and uncles
that you think are good people are
stealing that play that player real
stupid when it comes to that shell
checkout
a lot of people look the other oh i
don't know what i mean and they just
won't admit it to themselves the best
way to steal is right in someone's face
jesus jesus christ he just said that
like the ice man
[Laughter]
you should have pulled a gun
klinsky relax
[Laughter]
you're so trash that you think you're
not being trash and you're
like i know i'm being trapped the thing
that you're smart about it that's what's
scary
you're smart about it you know what
you're doing you're sinister
[Laughter]
she's smoking like a cigar ah after any
good heist
you're like the godmother of harlem over
here or who's that lady in miami
griselda bloggers it's probably here
you did she did yeah she doesn't do that
anymore hey
hey bill walsh you heard what i said one
year ago it was the last time
well what's yeah detergent what kind of
what kind of it was it one of the big
bulk ones yeah
i could see using that i always find
them to be the trashiest the big ones
that kind of ceiling's not fun that's
not the thrilling kind of ceiling that
what i'm the one i'm trying to tell you
about is in the face when
i go like at 7 11 i go like
i put these up there these up there this
up there and we goes to ring these i go
ah these are mine
oh my gosh [ __ ] that just that just sent
a chill through my spine
she looked me dead in the eye i felt
like i was just working at 7 o'clock no
one will ever question
that would you ever you're like harvey
airborne up there i was like what are we
going to stop and check the cameras i
gotta go
she flips a coin call it if they want to
check the cameras i go you know keep my
chips
has that happened no no one even
questions it
what are you like without weed are you
just stabbing people with ice picks yeah
i'm i'm without weed right now i haven't
smoked today really
yeah this is sober wow i'll let the
sixth precinct know
let the boys downtown though yeah give
me give me give him a fair fight
call in a couple more guys but i will
say that i do support small businesses
and i would never steal from someone's
house or personal property yeah
or anything like that uh dude i just
wanted to [ __ ] people over that are like
like [ __ ] walmart sure i got you they
pay their
employees like 35 cents an hour yeah
that's not good
don't have to pay them less than that on
the [ __ ] you're still yeah exactly
maybe if they can make a couple more
bucks they if
you guys spend so much on wall
prevention they'd be able to they'd be
able to they'd let their guys unionized
you're the problem that's the other
thing too buy nine more cameras and a
drone to follow you around
we got kim coming in over the best place
to steal
is from a place that uh is like a
walmart but is in a nicer neighborhood
because they don't get stolen from all
that so you actually have to help them
out
yeah because they have a certain amount
of items that are
there to be stolen they pay for that
yeah yeah yeah
so if i don't steal they're wasting
their own money
you could be like frank abagnale yeah
you're like one of them
yeah you're like one of the guys who
like writes bad checks gets caught by
the fbi then works for the fbi you're
helping them out now yeah you're showing
them how to do it yeah
would you take that game would you work
loss prevention yes
like in the casinos when they hire x
cheats to watch to watch the game
i've heard about that that's your kind
of job i love it
she's walking the catwalk in a walmart
the thought of robbing a casino gets me
off so much i'm going to slide off this
chair
[Laughter]
dude nobody's robbing a casino nobody's
robbing a casino but
it can't be i don't think it can be done
without somebody getting shot or heard
you're not getting it can be done it can
[Laughter]
are you jerry saperstein
have you seen my mom's feet are you mr
venetian
hey hey are you steve borgata are you a
fortnight fan at all
there was one time i was staying in a
hotel in vegas and
um i was laying in bed and the room
service people
just walked in as i was like watching tv
topless in bed
what she like didn't knock she's like i
didn't realize anyone was in here
and i was like so [ __ ] happy about i
was like oh and then she closed the door
and i was like
i'm getting this room for free the
wheels start turning they were trying
not to give me a room for free i
i called corporate no one answered i
went downstairs
then i found the guy who owns the hotel
on facebook and i think facebook called
him
video messenger over and over again
until he answered and gave me a refund
and he did
did he ever answer yeah he said i scared
him he was like no one's ever done this
before i'll definitely refund you i'm a
little taken back sorry
and i was like yeah no one's ever walked
in on me on my titties either
holy [ __ ] dude that's crazy
oh you're a little [ __ ] broncos that
was years ago that was like five years
ago
still i mean you're you tracked down the
owner of a host was it a big hotel or
like a
yeah no it was like a big hotel in vegas
he was like no one's ever facetime
messaged me to get a refund and i was
like
you have to get the condition she's
sinister i'm a little scared
gang after years of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by
big wireless providers if we've learned
anything we've learned that there's
always going to be a cat
they always get you they always get you
so when we heard about mint mobile
offering premium wireless service
starting at 15 bucks a month we thought
to ourselves okay
watch the catch but after speaking to
them after doing our own research we
found out
that it all makes sense and that there
isn't a catch
nothing there's no catch mint mobile
secret sauce is that they're the first
company to sell wireless servers online
only
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead cost
that could pass down to you in the form
of mystery fees instead
mint just passes on sweet savings
straight to you
yeah guys it is pretty remarkable uh
they
they've sent it to me we use it my wife
has actually been using it for like
three years
uh when she first moved here she needed
a card with and
you know the contracts and all that [ __ ]
they get you all hemmed up
so we did this three months she's
excited she just kept using it it's
cheaper it works just like a regular
phone
it's fantastic there's no reason to not
use it so cut the cord
get rid of the big guys and get on mint
mobile to get your new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month ship straight to
your door
for free go to mintmobile.com garbage
that's mint mobile.com garbage and cut
your wireless bill to just
15 bucks a month 15 bucks a month crazy
you're probably paying out the nose
right now 100 bucks 200 bucks you ain't
got limited overage
the whole nine yards mintmobile.com
garbage
cut your wireless bill to just 15 bucks
a month dudes
are you guys ready to hear the most are
you garbage heist of all time
a circus circus casino heist yeah
shout out to the circus we just talked
about it i'm going to admit that that
was the hotel
oh is this it really yeah
you tracked down the the the guy who
owned sir you tracked down mr circus
circus yeah
he had big shoes on i'm so upset you
said circus circus after that
i wasn't gonna admit that trashy part
circus
what it was the rooms were already like
five cents a night
what's in there like popcorn
a couple of elephants we'll send up some
cotton candy
right away
[Laughter]
sorry about that kid you really do
working on your acting chops over here
the housekeepers are all little people
for some reason
[Music]
oh we're having a good time this is a
good one what is it
all right so it was a chick who drove an
armored car for circus circus
i assumed it was the bearded lady
and she she drove the armature the
world's tallest man and the whatever oh
that one flatlined
still a good one though
that's that taquito's getting me all hot
and bothered so this
i don't even know if this counts as a
heist she just drove the truck and then
one day she was like [ __ ] it and just
drove off with all the cash
three million lived in the netherlands
for 12 years damn
never tracked her down in 2005 she just
turned herself in because she got tired
of living on the lamb
so what was her punishment i want to
know if it was worth it for her
i don't know i'll look into it i mean
three million in 12 years that's not
that much
trapeze no net all right
i heard of a really good [ __ ] heist
one time there was an old man that was
working at a zoo
he worked in the parking lot and he was
the person that um charged for
tickets parking tickets uh-huh and he
did it for like i think like 10 years or
something like that and then
one day he was just gone and they
realized they didn't charge for parking
there
he was charging like ten dollars a bus
five dollars a car and they did the math
he made like
100 million or something like he made
like hell of money
yeah yeah and he was just gone one day
the stand was gone
that's like yeah you just stand there in
a red jacket or whatever and people like
i guess this is the guy i don't know
what's going on
yeah the long con i like that huh that's
good
i knew it would have to be something
some kind of inside job i'm saying
there's no way that you're
you can't you can't smash it we're not
pulling up in [ __ ] penguin max and
getting out and [ __ ] robbing a casino
we won't make it out of the parking lot
no i'm not taking nothing that's worth
more than like 20 dollars
okay yeah do you still like jewelry like
those like oh no no i don't steal like
it's never like uh clothes no never
stuff anything down your shorts
no no no i'll do like a snickers but i'd
like like petty theft
i'm like a snickers bar detergent if
it's [ __ ] bothering me
sometimes i'll do a bag of chips if i i
do it as like a punishment like if i'm
waiting at 7-eleven for 10 minutes in
the line
i'm getting something for free kid's got
a point
i don't did you pay for all this stuff i
paid for all of it oh my god i didn't
even think of it
and my fingerprints stealing just for
the podcast
we're playing chess not checkers over
here fatty but i didn't want to get
arrested and not make it
she's like no this slurpee was mine
before i bought these
i'm only only charging me for two i
brought my own no these are my taquitos
yes yes i bought it from home i made
these
uh let's get into some questions let's
do it we got some [ __ ] fantastic
haters guys as you know when you join
the patreon we will answer your garbage
question we just get so many requests
otherwise it's the best way to [ __ ]
do it and a little added bonus to join
the old patreon
um which is cooking by the way
um this is just a [ __ ] home run this
is from tim is anybody in your family
missing a finger such a good question
that is a real dirtbag thing we're
talking tips are we talking about
fingers crossed the tip's always
attractive for some reason yes i'd
rather be missing
all like a whole hand than a tip yeah
because the whole hands it's like oh it
got wrapped around something
in the belly yeah yeah the tip is always
like the tail end of a truck something
and and the tip is we couldn't afford
the special surgery to get it put back
on back off
so it is what it is yeah they might take
a toenail and like
tape it on there or something like that
yeah i know somebody had that done a
toenail
yeah just to make it look make it look
normal he lost a tip and he lost the
finger and they put it yeah
so they took a pinky nail and kind of
put it in there not for me
it doesn't look right do anybody in your
family missing anything no but my dad
does have one of those crooked like top
thumbs from where it got cut
and like sewed back on you said that
like it was so normal a crooked top
like when someone's missing the top of
their thumb but it got so you kind of
this is kind of a yes
so yeah wait so
he lost sounds like a goal like it got
cut and then kind of got put back on the
wrong way
who put it on i don't know how did he
how did
i just know he's always had a [ __ ] up
missing piece of thumb that kind of got
put back on quick good
damn my one uncle has uh he [ __ ] up
his his finger and they couldn't get the
nerve back they didn't have the money to
put the tendon back together
so this thing just [ __ ] gets it's all
i don't know it's got his mind
he's always hitchhiking
[Laughter]
everybody's pulling over nah i'm just
waving to my buddy
this thing's just [ __ ] going the
other way 90 degrees all the time i
remember my buddy
my buddy's dad growing up he was missing
his got caught like a bike chain or
something and like they like
something happened he was missing so he
just had like this
and i'll never i didn't know and i'd
known him for like months and it was
like the first time i was eating dinner
over his house
and i looked and his dad's bored with it
and i was yeah they didn't tell me i was
like [ __ ] seven
i never met anybody missing a finger and
he's sitting
for a second that's a lot he's
[Laughter]
this is the same [ __ ] family gave me
milk with dinner for the first time
i was like yo wrap this up i'm out of
here i love the milk with dinner oh
yeah you do fantastic so trashy
pizza you like milk with pizza yeah of
course how else do you cool the pizza
down
coca-cola like a gentleman by the way
can we jump back real quick toby had
mentioned
his bagel situation earlier in the
podcast what are your thoughts on that
you're bi-coastal too
yeah be getting you going in you're in
new york you're getting a bagel with
cream cheese are you gonna toast it
see oh i really really like an untoasted
i like it toasted but there's something
better about the untoast
it doesn't like cut your mouth when
you're eating it fresh yeah it's so
chewy i love a chewy bread
oh love a big cb very good yeah she's
not all she's not all the way gone
[Laughter]
she's got some class in her yeah there's
some human in there
not much it's like it's like denying
science exists
no we have the technology
if you want to toast it and put butter
on it sure go for it but if you're doing
cream cheese
and your bagel can't be served untoasted
it sucks
i don't want a [ __ ] cold cold bagel
but the thing is when you toast them and
you're on the go then they're not
they stop being warm and then they're
just like these hard things
and that [ __ ] and that you can't get
cream cheese on the toaster bagel that
[ __ ] starts
yeah you're out of your league here i
will say this
i could see i could see a fresh out of
the oven
still warm from the oven bagel being the
the supreme leader of all bagels oh i
got news for you pinhead they don't cook
them in the oven
all right so take that [ __ ] back to
chicago all right they're boiled
and then placed in an oven all right
excellent i tried i mean
[Laughter]
i tried i can't get online but i'm
getting iced right now
i'm getting ice it's cold over there in
the booth
he's at a desk three feet away let's
pull the let's pull the curtain back
he's not in a boot
he's up there in the sound room
now yeah yeah of course by the way this
the spoon at the bottom of the slurpee
straw when i was six that was like
i felt i felt like a scientist with that
thing i had no idea what it did
really no idea you didn't couldn't
figure out what the spoon was i
didn't realize i didn't realize that was
you ever eat an ice cream yeah
i didn't realize that was for the
slurpee the [ __ ] would it be for you i
just thought it was like
it gave me a broken ticket i thought it
was just something cool they did i
didn't know that you were supposed to
do that oh you're a boss it's not i mean
in your defense it's not a great spoon
sure it never scoops up what you want it
to all right it's just enough
i thought it was designed that way so
you could get the chunks up through the
straw
it was so it was it was some safety
feature or something like a safety
feature whatever you want to call it
okay innovative technology
i can tell you are not the brains behind
the organization coffee as kids
coffee as kids you did in a bottle yeah
but that's
wait you know like but that's your thing
that's your background wait hold on
yeah like when i was young enough to
have a bottle cafe collection they gave
you
coffee and milk yeah that's how they do
it yeah when i was little my mom used to
drop me off at my aunt's house and she
was like your mom would drop you off and
you would like start crying for your
coffee like an old lady
or what are you puerto rican yeah jesus
you guys play it fast and [ __ ] loose
that the newbie newport game that they
started
no baby kim cries until she gets her her
fresh bur her oh my can't [ __ ] talk
today
hey what about that clown hotel jesus
christ wait before we move on to the
next question the the missing finger
maybe think of
think of one do any of you have any
permanent
like body issues like like a part of
your body yes
from my eyebrows to my ankles what
i'm all jacked now this is temporary
getting rid of this in a couple of weeks
just an ointment from the doctor
hopefully this will clear right up
just waiting on my copay to kick in
permanent ailments like a floating bone
somewhere or like you know i have i've
talked about it
i [ __ ] something up in my chest a
couple of years ago in colombia trying
to
uh wakeboard drunk and now it's like i
can crack it mine does that too
from jiu jitsu yeah i don't know what it
is it feels good when it cracks
it cracks but when it's not i'm like oh
it's i'm like it feels like it's caved
in and i'm like i gotta [ __ ]
and then you press and i feel good yeah
i don't know what it is
i like how hers is from jiu-jitsu and
uses from falling off a raft
in my defense i never even got up i was
just i was just being
pulled like a [ __ ] big fat bald fish
and they didn't speak any english my
spanish was no bueno and i was about 19
beers deep and i'm like i think i got
this
like tom cruise back there i do all my
own stunts for everybody out there
oh god uh i have a yeah i got all kinds
of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like neither you got like skin tags and
stuff neither oh skin tanks forget it i
usually take
by the way i'm such a hack i have for
sure had to make that joke at some point
fair enough yeah hey whatever i mean
let's tell you something
and they don't know that keep the keep
the fourth wall up um
going with that question does anybody in
this room have any pencil in them
permanently that was big that is so
[ __ ]
funny that's big let me tell you
something you're garbage
i got some right here in my finger and i
know a lot of people out there got a lot
of [ __ ] lead in them
yeah no no that's real bad no pencil no
i think i'm
shocked she didn't go to school that
much
too busy hanging out ah that's funny
harrison is a crayon only school the way
you just said that is so
cran he means crayons say it crayon
crayon
crayon crayon we said we grew up crowns
we say crowns
either way either way it's it's not
cramped it's crayon
all right hold on it's give me a cream
crayon crayon it's crayon what do you
think cranberry juice is
crayon cranberry juice crayon berries
crayon green apple in our house shout
out to ocean spray she always cut it
with a little something
um a crack pack of crayons yeah i would
say crayons
i did i cut my thumb on a tin can almost
a year and a half ago
and that [ __ ] still hurts why'd you have
a tin can i was trying to make like a
walkie-talkie
hey can you hear me over there i'm back
baby
i was slouched in the first half but
kepi's eating up over here since the
all-star
tell you that right now wow the
taquito's really hitting you
look a little more moderate jack for
being the boys
[Music]
uh what will you do with a can i was
just trying to make a
like a puerto rican drink
was there a coconut was there beans
involved
coconut milk condensed milk it all comes
in a can yeah so you were open
it sliced my finger it ruined
thanksgiving dinner i got it all blood
all over everything that we had been
cooking all day
oh really oh it was a squirter did
anybody eat it still or no no no
no it's not true blood
um that condensed milk though let me
tell you something
if that condensed milk you could drink
it out of the can i don't even i've
never even
[ __ ] with it like if milk was a candy
you ever had like a thai tea or anything
like that
or vietnamese iced tea i'm american baby
the four seasons that's it
i get skim milk and dunkin donuts
starbucks guys you need a thai tea
unless you had a thai tea
i don't know i don't yeah i don't [ __ ]
with it i haven't ventured i haven't i'm
still
i'm still in america when it comes when
it comes to food thai tea i'm not doing
i don't like thai food you're killing
our overseas markets here
i don't think we're big in thailand um
whatever next question
this one could be action heroes oh we
start doing [ __ ] commercials like
vinnie chase for all we know
um all right this is from ben did
you or anyone in your family ever own
one of those touch activated lamps
wait i don't even know what that is oh
touch actually yeah you can touch and it
goes on like it turns on and then
that was pretty classy i hate to say i
was gonna say that was too rich for us
that's what i
but this looking back now with some
perspective they're super trashy
no wait you're not talking about the the
round ones that like it looks like a
button that goes in the closet that runs
on batteries right
the tap lights yeah is that what you
have in your house maybe
we heard chandeliers just a bunch of
those we didn't have the touch ones we
had the ones that
you could clap though
that was a device yeah that was the fact
that you think that was the lamp is
scary
that was the device that was plugged
into the wall that was just our electric
going out
i didn't pay the bill yeah it's so weird
the lights always shut off on the 15th
for some reason
we must be clapping a lot um
my mom my mom and stepdad had the
clapper
in their bedroom up until it still might
even be there now i think about it but
up
until they started [ __ ] and the
lights would go on off
it's like a raven there
big guy's in there killing it dude
that's i was literally about to
ask if anyone had a clapper and i was
like no one had a clap yeah we have
i mean there's probably it's probably
still plugged into the wall everybody
got one of those for christmas in 1988
everybody doesn't matter who you are you
got one everybody got one
now those lights on the other hand i
started seeing those maybe
early 90s at my cousin's house who had a
little bit more keys the touch ones
yeah it was like a nice those were
[ __ ] insane i thought they were fake
just
huh huh uh-huh talk about entertainment
little fat kid
this is why i think they're trashy
because it's not that
it's not classic i think it is that's
what i'm saying we're
trash so we think that we're going ooh
that's nice well what would be it's just
a touch no it's for sure trashy yeah i
agree with you but they're nice lamps
they're the first they're the classy of
the trashy yes
i've seen them in like like a lamp that
would could just easily have one of
those things in it it
was just as nice i understand that they
look the same yeah
yeah but i say you're not going over
like some rich person's house and
walking up to the lamp and doing this
no one's ever had to tap their lamp in a
mansion yes they don't think no
no they got the faders yes
turn on all the [ __ ] lights yeah so
you have to set the mood and it'll go
down low
they have the whole thing growing up we
had the slider in one room that would
and like
we viewed that as like fan we're like
well this is where company can see right
i have one slider so put it down so then
see the carpets are dirty
there was dog piss and [ __ ] stains all
over that carpet dude
shout out to rusty dead cat in the
corner yeah yeah go
um man that's [ __ ] funny i don't know
man
i think that's pretty classy they're not
they're trashy dude they're trashy for
sure
uh take where would you buy them now
that's what i'm saying you weren't
buying goodwill yes
exactly you weren't you're only gonna
get a nice one out of home goods home
goods ain't classy home goods this is
just all
oh what are you out of your [ __ ] mind
this is not classy
yes it is no it's not your home goods is
all [ __ ] they didn't sell at bed bath
and beyonce
it's a tj maxx they're unique pieces
it's literally
attached to a tj maxx in my hometown you
have to leave out of the same access
same thing yeah same thing here they're
all in the store
it's they just yes it's trash saying
home goods as fancy is like saying ikea
is fancy
yes is it time for a commercial
one time i insulted someone and it went
into their nice place i was like this is
nice it was like i was 20.
i was like this looks like an ikea and
he was like well we bought really
expensive furniture
but thank you oh i thought that was a
sense of furniture
it's still when i say you guys got a
bob's around here holy
[ __ ] i still be like yeah we got the
couch and i can't like that
is fancier to me in my dirt ball head
it is still like a badge of honor i mean
we did get it from the
the the unboxed there's an on craigslist
there is a section myspace marketplace
there is a section
in ikea where it's like loose stuff
like stuff that's either been returned
the island of unwanted times yes
or like the box is open and we've
definitely got we got that couch from
there
yeah that's a really nice couch well let
me ask you this so
if you're telling me home goods is no
good which i think
i think they have great stuff there plus
they're you're also trash
that's what you have to zoom out they're
no good yeah but they're saying no
what's people aren't shopping there
right people are going to like west
i think it's called west west west elm
all right uh
restoration hardware a lot of cash okay
that's a lot of
couple bucks huh dude the couch has to
be over 1500 for it to be a fancy place
the pillows have to be
60 each i feel like you can easily find
a 1500 couch at home goods
with a grill in it
and a clapper got a cooler under that
[Laughter]
did your couch recline as a kid like did
you have like the
our parents always went see the thing is
my um
do you have brothers and sisters i have
three sisters okay i'm the oldest
um and my stepdad his parents were
classier than us
they were like the classy family and
what they would do is they would have
seen him with the long hair and the
no i mean he's not okay yeah it didn't
get he looks very my step-dad by the way
yeah he's very my step-dad yeah
he looks like he could have been a
peanut butter falcon or something
i don't know what that is but i agree
with once you guys watch the movie
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
love that one
shout out to shia la la buff so his
parents were they would give us
their furniture so we always got like
the really nice [ __ ]
he was he's the favorite child out of
their three kids so
we got like their fancy entertainment
center we had their fancy
couch we even had the recliner with the
now we have the recliner with the
usb where you could charge your phone in
it i feel like that's wait
wait a minute wait a minute wait i feel
that's trash no that's just fine
you're gonna [ __ ] on home goods she's
got a massage chair from a car wash in
her house
i didn't say we're the [ __ ]
kardashians
[Laughter]
it's the sa is the entertainment center
still there yeah and it's so nice
it's like what's in it it's a huge
wooden entertainment center it's
a bunch of dvds
it's like and it's even got like hidden
like it looks like a column and you like
pull it out it's just a hidden drawer of
dvds
at one point i know that entertainment
yes
that's where that's where tony soprano
kept the ar-15 oh yeah he opens it up
what the [ __ ] yeah there's a grenade in
there
what's sad is we had those things but we
never had the cd
we never had the cd volume to pull it
off oh you know it even looked worse
yeah like you'd open it and it'd fall
over because there wasn't enough
standing up
you have to put them on the bottom
basketball next to it you have to lay
them down so you can't even see the
title when you open it oh the cd rack
man that was something we had we had a
big one it was a big wooden one
like tv in the middle then two big
wooden tower it was like [ __ ] you
know nine feet tall or whatever
and there was for sure time periods
where like there was like glass doors
with the shelves and like the shelves
were just empty you know
like there was just no they were for
like a radio or whatever but wait you
know
the china cabinet in your house is a
little suspect too china cabinets
wow yeah that's a that's a white trash
thing is it yeah that's not hispanic
trash
is it no china county i don't think we
do china as much
really we don't [ __ ] with china like we
have
we have some it's just also you know
yours is real mitch matt and i think
there's a couple of bar glasses in there
too oh well
what's the one like the one in the
kitchen yeah yeah that's you have two
china cabinets yeah we have a little bit
of cash he's got one
yeah but he's got one in the kitchen
it's it's like a little too big it kind
of like
it kind of leans over the doorway a
little bit
looks like they're still moving we're
not quite sure where to put it
ah that one's more like everyday just
like
because they won't get rid of anything
so there's like post-it notes and [ __ ]
they're bonkers they're [ __ ] i don't
know what they were garbage i don't know
what to tell you
we're garbage with some money have any
of you ever owned anything from
sharper image that's rich to me i don't
know that's rich stuff oh it's trash i
know it's that in sky mall dude if
you're ordering out of sky mall [ __ ]
keep it we we got near sharper image my
dad slapped our hands don't [ __ ]
touch it
yeah we were a
that's where i got my metal detector
shout out you get all your electric
ashtrays you want in there but stay at a
sharper image
[Laughter]
no sir that's like brook stones or
whatever it's called brooks brother i
don't know anything with brooks we don't
we don't [ __ ] with it
we are not a brook i can't afford to go
into the brooks
do you know brook stones i've heard of
it it's like a fancy
[ __ ] is it where they sell massage
chairs and stuff like that like 400
this is how trashy we are we don't even
know what they sell
i just like massage chairs i'm like i
think no i think that's the place we
used to just go in and get massages
for a few minutes i'll be back i'm going
to the spa today no i think that
legitimately my mom would be like we can
stay here for 45 minutes till they kick
us out
okay okay well that sounds like a great
mystery yeah it's like uh well it's like
a sharper image type stuff
do you remember getting kicked out of
places when you were a kid
because you because of you hey no
lawyers are your parents yeah
has that ever happened um yeah probably
it sounds familiar i think i've blocked
it all out i get i'm getting kicked i
have like a
trauma of being embarrassed as an adult
like i don't like [ __ ] being
embarrassed that's why i had to stop
stealing because i can't
stand the thought of being arrested um
and my parents were always kicked out of
places so oh my
god man restaurants that's given me
anxiety
i'm sure my mom
we when i was back home we went i had a
show in orlando
and her and my aunt came out and they
were like let's go to this
uh all you can eat lobster place we used
to go to and you're never a good sign
here's
all you're getting about a red flag
well i don't know if i said this on the
last podcast the same lobster place what
they used to do when me and my cousin
were kids me and my cousin were nine
months apart so we
and my mom's we're both single moms so
we grew up together real trashy stuff
i got you so two sisters raising their
kids you guys live together
yeah oh that's awesome yeah so my mom
and our sister would be fist fighting i
mean my cousin would be fist fighting it
was all so trashy
wait really yes like 20 years old with
kids
oh my god that's awesome and living
together so they'd be fighting me my
cousin would fight but then there'd be
times where my mom and my aunt would go
to this
all-you-can-eat lobster place and they
didn't want to take us because it was
too expensive to take the whole family
so they would literally
before they left they would line their
purses with aluminum foil
and they would go to the all-you-can-eat
lobster place and they would stuff like
five or six lobster into their bag then
they'd eat a couple real quick
check out and then come home and make
like potatoes and
and make it dinner and then make a
dinner with the lobster let me tell you
something right now
those are two good moms right there
doing what they had to do
they did [ __ ] respect them yeah they
could have [ __ ] iced just completely
they could have just enjoyed their
[ __ ] bringing it back to the
fam i don't know i'm sorry i can't go
inside
could you imagine getting pinched for
that [ __ ] person
you got an aquarium in your purse when
you're walking out they smelled so bad
coming in
bad and they would have specific purses
for that
yeah they would have all you can take
that to home all you can eat purses
first um so we went back there for the
first time since i was a kid and my mom
was like it's the best
do they have all you can eat lobster
this place you've never been there
i've never physically been interested in
like disney world
you've had that it was only a rumor i've
only heard of this place
it does exist it had a giant lobster
on top of a car in the front of it it's
like that kind of trash
dude like that it was like it's not
fresh lobster
no i think they use pieces of that
lobster
yeah yeah yeah you're getting some day
olds i walked in and this place looks so
[ __ ] disgusting of course
it looks so [ __ ] disgusting this is
covid
era i walk in it looks so nasty there's
not much food
uh they're charging us 65 70 bucks was
there a lobster tank
no oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the way that i watch my mother change
into a different person which because
the thing is yeah it's 65 dollars but
you have a two hour limit
so for some reason where you're going
somewhere with a time limit
is [ __ ] trash now 65 you got at least
the two lobsters for that to be
uh financially uh you probably get other
stuff other than lobster too right
there's others they load you up on like
bread they probably drop a big basket of
bread or something oh no not our family
yeah we're like don't save the bread
stop talking we gotta go did the time
start like it was like
it was like an olympic sport you guys
are tying your shoes yeah my mom and ann
are putting their hair up
it's like supermarket sweeps for
dirtbags
which is all ready for dirtbags
yo i would [ __ ] kill supermarket
sweets oh it looks so fun
oh well i thought that it wasn't a real
grocery store i was crushed
so so my mom is eating lobster faster
than i've
ever ever seen anyone eat i had this guy
that i was dating with me and she was
cracking them
so fast that he was like getting the
juices on his face
he was she was aggressively eating
lobster and then she'd tell my aunt like
get up get up i have to go get my next
one
and it became this huge thing it was
like this race at one point she was like
i've had six already you know
six laps i think that's good on her
seventh i caught her at the buffet
she's got tentacles that's too much
mercury
on her seventh lobster tail i caught her
at the buffet there's no one
in this place there's no rush she is
standing in front of the dude that like
because it's a buffet but it's covered
so they have to actually put it on a
plate you asked for what you want now
um and she's standing in front of the
dude and she's chanting
while he's picking up the lobster the
biggest
one the biggest one and this dude just
[ __ ] hates his life and he's just
it was so embarrassing oh my god
that's insane my mom she was chanting
the biggest one and then she made me
take a slow-mo video of her eating
a lobster because she thought it was
gonna be sexy and it was not it's really
bad
yikes oh if my mom ever asked me to take
a slowpoke video for doing anything
i'm [ __ ] emancipating myself i don't
care if she's right
don't brought it i'll [ __ ] well she
would look good if it wasn't for the
goggles and the headband
[Laughter]
are we wearing lobster bibs at this
point uh yes does it matter i mean she's
[ __ ]
she's chanting at an all-you-can-eat
lobster buffet that one
with a with a car with a lobster on the
front at one point she's bragging to the
server whenever he comes by she's like
i've already had six and i was like stop
you're gonna get fired sweating there's
lobster meat all over her face
she's like the opposite of david portnoy
she's just sinking small business during
that
yeah he's dumb lobster people never saw
me coming
i've already had six and stole 12 lemons
oh she does that too she'll do the lemon
and the sugar to make lemonade
really absolutely thanks for watching
and i'm just like i tell her i'm like
i'll just buy them
two weeks ago i'll buy the lemonade yeah
stop
oh but i tell you what for all her flaws
all right you got to remember she
brought that [ __ ] lobster back for
you
it's a warm moment no matter what you
should they brought it back i'll never
they could have stayed there got banged
up [ __ ] met some dudes went off
whatever
no they wanted to get back to the kids
they wanted to bring their kid those
that cold
probably it couldn't have been good
yeah yeah i mean that wasn't
refrigerated on the way home
[ __ ] my house how far is it i don't
know like an hour
tell us in a hot episode we've only
gotten a [ __ ] two questions she's the
garbage queen man i know really
really really really is yeah we got to
put you and kcb
in like the thunderdome face-off yeah
kcb was super [ __ ] trash too
really yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just
waiting for your mom's foot to come in
um whatever what i don't know
um all right this is from joe this guy
was coming down i'm so hungover
uh this is from joe were you born
anywhere other than a hospital
we're hospital people my whole family
i'm a hospital [ __ ]
yeah yeah toby
uh no
i was gonna say
[ __ ] midwife in a kiddie pool over
here you know now they're teaching women
how to have orgasms while they give
birth
to make it pleasurable instead of
painful well that's got to do something
to the kid that kid ain't coming out
right
imagine coming out in your mom's [ __ ] oh
ew
well i mean you're already in a bunch of
other stuff
but still but still the purpose of it
why you came out you're just in her jizz
who's teaching that i saw that on
youtube
it's not like tom brokaw covered it you
think it sounds like it was a master
class
yeah it's kevin spacey it's weird
i saw it on youtube i'm dame judy and
i'm here to teach you how to come
while you give birth to your baby i read
it in an article it was a meme
but it was a meme it was a meme and a q
a
group an article nonetheless
it was published somewhere reptilian
weekly
oh man um this one is a [ __ ] home run
and i never thought sometimes they just
[ __ ]
hit the nail on the head that one was
pretty good
they're [ __ ] great they're they're
really getting good at these uh this is
for me and you ever
i love how they just write it as us you
ever buy candy from a place you know
you're not supposed to
like a staples or a ross or something
[Laughter]
hey the candy at the line at t.j.maxx
hits differently it does
anytime i'm in a state's movie can't be
here they don't [ __ ] around
anytime i'm in a staples i'm like for
some reason that bag of jolly ranchers
looks [ __ ] fantastic
dude because i listen i know exactly
what you're talking about okay and
as as a critical lifelong fat kid
here's the thing you go into stores like
that and your brain
is [ __ ] conditioned for there to be
a [ __ ] coke uh freezer in the front
and some kind of [ __ ] candy uh like a
butterfinger
some skittles something something should
be there but for a long time it wasn't
that's what i'm saying i think when
you're in staples you're not thinking
about candy and then you see candy and
you go oh great like i didn't know i
could get no i'm saying you expect it to
be there but it isn't there and you know
when they got wise what they started
doing first
they started dropping those big things
of [ __ ] twizzlers
and that's when it started to turn
around right next you know they got hot
dogs in there it's [ __ ] awesome
america was back oh the best those
those big things are twizzlers ain't
nothing to shake a stick at either
the single jawns i don't [ __ ] with
twizzlers what really
they taste like candle wax what do you
love any kind of licorice
no really she does have a refined
palette
i'm a little classier though it's crazy
she should have used the spoon i tried
to swirl my slurpee but nothing moved
she's so good that she made me feel bad
for that i don't know why like wait a
minute she is diabolical
she's getting drawn butter from her
mom's purse
let's see what else i brought in here
for you boys sushi
out of my flesh
um all right this is from ben uh is it
garbage to combine the leftovers of two
different bags of frozen products i eat
fries or tots
if you don't have enough in one bag to
make a full portion so if you're eating
like half curly fries half
tater tots you're a genius yeah it's
true it's trashy though because they're
typically always freezer burned too
so bad the way that i thought the
freezer burn was an actual flavor
growing up
i was like i hate when she buys this
brand
you just thought that's how purdue made
them yeah that's [ __ ]
garbage i'll say this though
uh i think it's garbage to not use them
all in one sitting when are
when are you not knocking through a box
it's when people need to save a little
bit that is garbage when people
save a little bit of food i do that well
you always cook it because we don't want
the freezer burn thing in there because
then [ __ ]
then you put something else in there
then you're knocking over the tater tots
and the little pieces are falling out
everywhere i think it's like that big
bag of tater tots
you can do the whole bag unless you're
by yourself yeah
how big are these bags are your families
buying the big taters
yeah like multiple portions oh when you
were a kid they were probably buying
chicken fingers
they were buying tyson [ __ ] tenders
why were the ones tasty fries do you
remember tasty fries what am i an
[ __ ]
i remember chicken fries from burger
king well i mean i had them i had them
like a couple of weeks ago and they're
not
as good as they used to be really yeah
when they first dropped
they were [ __ ] something else they're
not as good anymore
are you trying not to hiccup right now
it came out
um all right this one's from josh uh did
you ever think convertibles were for
rich people
yes for sure did and kind of still do
yeah
my mom got a sebring a red sebring
convertible and i literally thought we
were like we were the kennedys
yeah this is [ __ ] we are rich people
is this manual or automatic the top
coming down
because the because the crank cranking
down the hell i didn't even know
who even got that far yeah that means
you would have to know somebody that had
a convertible
no we had it was the button when you hit
the button
i felt like a transformer dude i was
like i'm [ __ ] killing it
pops up i got into i got into a mustang
a few months ago uh
and the chick was like was like you put
the top down and then she had to hand
crank it i was like
this is no good this is killable the
convertible mustang in general is
[ __ ] garbage
it's so good that's gym teacher [ __ ]
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's gym teacher [ __ ] um but a
convertible is actually when you get in
one and like
say if you have like it was probably
brutal in the winter wasn't it
because that [ __ ] don't do nothing for
you yeah no it was cold yeah
cold it's a leak every now and then fake
rear window that's not it's plastic yeah
yeah yeah
it's a tough one nope i'll take a moon
roof any day what were your family cars
growing up um
growing up we had a
an 84 lobster damn i can't remember
they were never great cars though i mean
i'm picturing there was a nissan
probably thrown in there
there was definitely a nissan we had a
nissan we had a
i in high school i drove an astro what's
that the vans
you drove in you know what they are like
who are you i drove an ice sheet what
color was it it was
uh like a beige dude those things were
always those things always smelled like
rotten eggs
coaching little league i know what are
you talking about why would you be
driving that because
it was my parents card and they let me
have it this thing what one
i'm surprised you were allowed on school
property with that thing yeah that's
pedophile it was actually fun because
i surfed in high school we took all the
seats out and we put surfboards there
you go that is pretty cool
you have to make it you have to be cool
or you [ __ ] or it [ __ ] sucks you have
to be cool and let your friends [ __ ]
back there or like you're going to be a
loser yeah of course you can't take that
seriously what color was yours
that color that that color that's what i
was rolling up in
with whether it's with those tints in
the in the rears yeah
well that's actually pretty hot right
there but that's a draw that's
i mean that's a real picture that's like
it looks like this one's higher than
that this one's got a little [ __ ]
spark this is a drawing it's got 22's on
it yeah this is a [ __ ]
that drawn one's like the 18th i like
how they put this one out in the desert
like what the [ __ ]
that's cause i got stuck there
there's a couple of dead bodies in there
they found the driver a mile dead with a
gunshot wound to the back of his head
yeah we had that we had um god just some
shitty cars i can't
you said enough don't don't worry yeah
i mean you were driving an astro man to
school i picked that
i don't think you were in any bmws does
your family have i'm curious i just i
picture it
do they have any of those three wheel
things with the two wheels in the front
one in the back
but when we see one the way that they
like
that was the funniest answer to that wow
that's good
one of these days they get excited
they don't have them but they do get
excited when they say it yeah wow
what do you think your folks would be
like if they had uh tomorrow they hate
the lottery unlimited
i didn't know it would take it would
take dealers for everybody
i have no idea it wouldn't be good it
wouldn't be good i tell my family like i
feel like yeah thank god i started doing
stand-up and got out
because i come back and i'm like wow i
really was impressed by this [ __ ] like
three years ago
yeah like three years ago i would have
been like look at that three-wheeled
thing
yeah that's so badass oh god
all right this one i mean this is just
funny this isn't even a real question
ever listen to ac dc on a speed boat yes
of course yeah i've never been oh you
were a boat family growing up there was
one you showed up i think you showed us
the one in your backyard
yeah we had two in the yard both of them
didn't well that's pretty good that
takes a little bit of cash
two non-working boats in your backyard
it's bad when they're not in the water
in florida
every year when they got their taxes
back they bought another broken boat i
swear
but they had something in the water i
would imagine and somehow we always got
in the water it would break down for a
little bit while we were out there and
then we'd figure out how to get back
that's why that's poor person boat you
know how many times
you're out there and then you're like ah
the prop fell off or whatever
[Laughter]
my mom was like you [ __ ] idiot he was
diving in the water looking for it
really yeah i was like you're not gonna
be able to get it back
up that's scary that's crazy
holy [ __ ] i was lost in there the image
of somebody
some poor guy and i think the last thing
he said to my mom
i can picture him too because i've seen
him and he's like he's kind of a
know-it-all you know he doesn't let my
mom get awarded even though she's
usually right and i think the last thing
he was like don't tell me how to run my
boat mary
just for sure was don't tell me how to
run my boat man like it's
a cruise ship it's [ __ ] three people
drunk on a pontoon
it was a pontoon of course it was below
deck
we bring three speakers they're all dead
i'm like why do we have three and
they're all dead he's like well this one
doesn't work i'm like then throw it away
yeah they keep things that are broken
that's a trashy thing too if something
breaks that you always have
the thought that you're going to just
fix it yeah also in your head you go
well this is technology it's valuable i
can't throw this out right
how's the speaker dead i don't
understand like you like a bluetooth
like a bluetooth
yeah it doesn't come with a sound system
now that's broken too yeah i i mean when
i went back home i was shocked to see
how many things like my stepdad is a
nice job he works for the government
he gets paid very well and i'm like why
am i opening the dryer with
with a sandwich knife is that what you
have to do yes you have to stick it in
the crack and like because the
handle broke it's not about money it's
instinct yeah it's just
it's just dna yeah the for some reason
the locks are backwards in the house
i love it so they lock like you can get
locked in the house
[Laughter]
is we got to get to the lobster please
your stepdad throwing it at me he's like
no we don't have it right here
check my purse yo i've never heard of
that [ __ ]
that's nuts you gotta break out of your
house yeah that's crazy
that's something else that's trashy and
i've been in people's places where they
had the
their sockets were upside down or like
they were installed wrong or like the
light switch goes sideways
you ever seen that the [ __ ] are we i
don't know [ __ ]
spaceship or something i hate seeing
something that's so it's one of my
things from like my childhood seeing
something that's fixable just be broken
that's a lot of my house yeah and like
you just see someone that has like a
light bulb out in their kitchen
it's for a month and it's like it takes
you two seconds just fix the [ __ ]
light bulb
that's that's our that's our house can't
fight city hall
can't get these permits bolted oh my god
all right let's do uh let's do one more
here yes
uh fantastic maybe two all right uh this
is from brian
shout out to brian rizzy who sent us a
very nice [ __ ] uh he sent us the
state quarters
ah thank you collection um and what else
did he say
i'm upset at how much this looks like my
home yeah yeah this is all [ __ ] from our
we went back to our parents house and
just took all this [ __ ] from our parents
house yeah
um he says how far away is acceptable
acceptable and we've touched on this how
far away is acceptable to push your cart
into the corral
like if you're at a target you have the
car and you're in the parking lot dude
that's a [ __ ] that's a chip shot
how do you like where where will you
leave the cart in the parking lot
anywhere as long as it crosses that line
it's a touchdown baby
[ __ ] that will you like put the two
front wheels on a curve so it stays
there
i always put it back shockingly you put
it back in the correct
because you're a nice person you just
you just throw it in there you don't
line it up and [ __ ]
no you get it change the oil and [ __ ]
like that i just throw it in there but i
make sure
yeah it's back home trying to make it
easy for the people
the rest of my family just will let my
mom will let it go and just watch it
roll into the [ __ ] highway
i'm like you know it's going to scratch
someone's car yeah
before you leave do you wipe it for
prince no
i can't let anybody know i was here set
it on fire
we actually have a shopping cart at our
house
oh that was always a tough look you will
go somewhere there was like a home depot
[ __ ] shopping cart at someone's house
how did you get this yeah how'd you get
this oh
who touched you yeah something's wrong i
always got scared when we were driving
on the highway and you see a shopping
cart like off to the side
on the on the shoulder yeah you're like
what happened to the shopper
think there's so many food left mom pull
over
um all right this is from alex shout out
to alex uh have you ever have you or if
i've ever been to a demolition derby
yeah yeah she answered that like she was
in college i've never been in one uh no
but that's what we used to do as like a
family we used to go watch the monster
truck rallies
where do you live in florida again um
not the nice park
not miami central florida but you're
near the water
uh yeah we're about 20 minutes away from
the water we're close to orlando
in between orlando and the beach so you
kind of have the beach and you have that
kind of side of florida but then you
also have
yeah i mean we're 20 minutes away from
like rich people but we live
in like i might like i said my parents
have well water like
well well water we found out we thought
it was trashy but it's very classy
i don't think in florida i don't think
it doesn't smell classy
it's supposedly horrible you get out of
the shower you smell like eggs
oh god and nobody in my house no
nobody my house smells it anymore i'm
like what's going on yeah
my stepdad specifically bought a house
in the part of the town that still has
well water
and i'm like what was his reasoning i
don't know he's an idiot no there must
be some old school reason for you
maybe he saved 50 bucks but i'm like but
i'm like you should have just bought a
house where
you could have nice water wouldn't you
want and now every week he has to go to
publix does it fill up one of those
water things
they have
it jesus christ no you can't drink the
water give her something do we have a
trophy or something
i'll take the rest of your slurpee
[Laughter]
are you kidding me uh yeah you can't
drink and there's other
where is it mars what the [ __ ] going
on dude i don't know there's something
it smells
so rancid it is insane oh it's probably
gatorade
like eggs it smells like you know when
you have you know when you make eggs and
it's like sticks on your hands like that
smell
that's what you smell like when you
leave after you're soaked that's the
clean way
so you so that's what my buddy's astro
vein smelled like growing up
what about to brush your teeth you use
that water yeah you use the well water
yeah
ooh okay so but you're in the dominican
republic nobody's drinking the water
like nobody
i've never seen anybody drink the water
it's a big mountain
so where does he go to publix as a
grocery store right
yeah so he goes to buy or they have like
a water station they have like a water
station
and everything's free i know he pays and
gets us filled up a couple times a week
it's a big hassle
the wall sometimes there nobody goes so
there's just no water in the house for a
few days dude that's like dystopian what
the
[ __ ] is going on insane to me that's
crazy
i mean i would have specifically paid
more money for a house to live in a
place where i could
i'll give the money to knowledge forget
about the locks on the windows or
whatever you were talking about that's
[ __ ]
it's so bad that's just locking yourself
in a house where you can't drink the
water that
is the epitome of trash
somebody open the door and bring us some
water thank god we got three days of
water left no you don't
it was rough damn [ __ ] yeah that's
hardcore
yeah oil water well you're out there
there's nothing like trying to
boil water to make rice and you're using
bottled water you're just doing one
bottle at a time then throwing it out
and like it's like that's a tough
wasteful that's not even
that's surviving that's like you're like
that that's like man vs
wild yeah it's like chernobyl jesus
christ kim
yeah so make sure you subscribe to my
twitch yeah make sure
you get a well of her had a hard life
also all right i have one more this is
i don't know not a lot of i didn't know
about it but a friend of mine's family
had one this is from sean has anyone in
your family owned a pizzazz
i don't even know what that is no but i
thought that was a personality type do
you know what a pizzazz is
dog the pizzazz is the most personal
cooking instrument ever
this will change your this will change i
thought it was like moxie
there's like a [ __ ] super hot heat
lamp under here and this thing spins
it turns and you're burning pizza and
you can put frozen mozzarella sticks for
frozen any you can okay hooks anything
okay that sounds trashier but i like
it's got like a lid
and on on the underside of the lid it's
got the heat lamp
and so you put the lid on top of the
tray
and it heats okay i don't see it though
but all right same
same concept are you describing like a
chicken incubator yes that's exactly
what it looks like it looks like a
chicken incubator it works
incredibly oh new wave n-u-w-a
nothing was coming i was trying to
co-sign like nothing's coming up on
heatwave but it looks great
yeah and you made it up i'm lying i'm a
millionaire just a bunch of german
new wave oven let's try that
the pizzazz this thing oh this looks
medical it's incredible
this looks like it sterilizes things
listen you buy it at ace
apparently you can only get it
you can only get it in boardwalks for
all you're fine it is
incredible i think everyone should own
one of these
that looks weird
got started i don't want to see my food
as it's cooking
i don't want to be able to see it from
all angles yeah keeps running up against
the glass
yeah oh god all right that's it right
sperm in it you can
pick the sex of your baby oh i like the
one on the left
we're breeding clones in the well you
know you know it's one thing though that
i didn't
wanted to mention that i do because of
trash because i
grew up trashy please is whenever i go
out to eat
even if i'm still hungry i'll save half
the meal for later
isn't that so poor really if i'm like
not full i'll be like you know what let
me just cut it in half so that i can
have dinner later and i can afford
my dinners now i respect but in my head
i'm like oh i can make
one meal into two there are there are
there are good traits from garbage
like what you said about your mom and
the lobster we touched on that several
times
and doing something like that you know
what i mean it makes you appreciate
because you appreciate it
right yeah it's pretty good look at that
you're not just having fun here we're
growing
and we're learning ken cogden everybody
kim is there anything you want the folks
out there to know you got coming up late
on him uh yeah
hit him with everything of course you
guys can follow me on twitter at
kimberly congdon you can follow me on
tiktok and instagram
kim kongden uh check me out on twitch.tv
queen kong one that's c-o-n-g one
um and you can subscribe for free on
amazon prime and please please please
check out my podcast broad topics
t-o-p-i-x
it's available anywhere you find
podcasts youtube itunes google play
stitcher or on the gas
digital network absolutely fantastic
what an episode
what a time funny [ __ ] great thing
fantastic
what do you got for him uh as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes youtube and
patreon also guys uh important
information about the live shows
uh we i will be fat and i'll be
bald uh we did had we added a third show
in chicago so get those [ __ ] tickets
that's probably gonna sell out too
we added a second show in atlantic city
that's probably gonna [ __ ] sell out
so get
those tickets baby also indy uh the same
week as chicago june 23rd i believe
uh so get those tickets as well also
boston
rhode islander on sale uh we have some
more jersey and baltimore dates coming
up as well
they're out we're coming get ticks we
love you we'll see you next week
peace